Jacob Riis going to talk about data
structures for semi strict thanks a lot
Mike hi everyone okay so my microphones
clearly working I'm going to tell you
about data structures for semi strict
higher categories so I'm starting a bit
late I'll try not to I'll try to be as
quick okay all right so this talk is all
about higher dimensional algebra what on
earth is higher dimensional algebra well
what is ordinary algebra this is
something that we learn from a young age
we arrange symbols in a line okay and
these things have some meaning we could
be in any number of different specific
settings we could be doing calculus we
could be doing group theory we could be
doing lots of things but something we're
familiar with is arranging symbols in a
line manipulating those symbols applying
equations and so on but there's no
reason that we need to restrict
ourselves to arranging our symbols in
lines we can arrange our symbols in
higher dimensional spaces we could
arrange our symbols in a two dimensional
space say a three dimensional space or
in a higher and even higher dimensional
space where things become harder to
visualize so what's the point why is
this interesting why is this rich
because once you're in a high
dimensional space suddenly any any
homotopy any isotopy of the space in
which you're embedding can act on your
composite okay so any way that we could
take say of taking this planar diagram
and doing some planar isotopy we could
ask for example that that this composite
we start with and that that isotopic
composite should have the same
interpretation in terms of our
underlying structures so you get a lot
of rich geometry and rich connection was
between algebra and geometry in this
high dimensional setting now where do
these pictures come from why don't we in
fact see these pictures very much in
modern mathematics if they're so natural
and so important well features that we
might see for example in category theory
papers would be pictures like this this
is called a pasting diagram picture like
this and the idea is that ABCDEF or
categories these single bar dois arrows
functors and the double barred arrows
which run vertically are natural
transformations and they've got names s
and T so this is a pasting dagger it's
very different to the diagrams we just
saw before but if we realize this
diagram that means everything that was a
point before becomes a region everything
that was a horizontal horizontally
tending arrow becomes a vertically
tending wire and this thing s and these
things s and T which were filling in
these cold regions they now label points
what we get is a diagrammatic copious
representation of exactly the same
geometrical information ok so the
graphical conkers representation is the
dual daggers not fundamentally encoding
any different sort of information as
these more traditional diagrams and the
idea is in that in general we would
expect n categories to have an
n-dimensional graphical calculus ok and
for N greater than 2 this is not really
a theorem this is something that it's an
expectation it's something that would
motivate perhaps are they're very
definitions of n categories so what's
the point of high dimensional algebra
what impact does it have why should we
study it at all
well there are a range now of very
striking applications striking in the
strong sense that in a hundred years
people will look back I claim on these
applications to think wow that was a
that was a real achievement of 21st
century mathematics or ever it is so I
would mention here homotopy type theory
topological field theory and higher
tapas theory right this guy looks a bit
like mike zuckerberg this is jacob
blurry he's too cool to put a shirt on
but that's his that's well john was too
cool to for the shirt on as well in that
region and so i mean these are just like
this what what i think are going to
going to be look back on us they're
super impressive right epoch making
applications so cause they're a huge
number of of other applications right
concurrent see quantum computing all
sorts of all sorts of things all sorts
of things and that's gram c got mass
Michael it's yeah yeah that's right the
people who do it must be type theory
obviously don't put their face on I
could have got their faces as well
there's lots of faces like I've chosen
ok
but why is this a subject that people
think is a bit difficult right we're
doing science lots of stuff is maybe
ostensibly difficult so here's a quote
from Jacob brewery how I came to be
there is generally regarded as a
technical and forbidding subject so why
is this why does it have this reputation
well even from a relatively simplified
perspective this word semi strict means
we throw away as many of the axioms as
we can just to make the system we're
working with as simple as possible
a true category that is something with a
two dimensional notation comprises three
sets six functions and twelve axioms a
three category crisis four sets nineteen
functions and 58 axioms are for category
comprises roughly five sets thirty-four
functions at 118 axioms okay so it's
really it's really horrendous it's
really impossible to even conceive of
doing any sort of formal work certainly
in this sort of setting almost in this
setting and this setting people just
about manage it right if you want to
formally prove that your theorems are
correct that you're not making any
mistakes if you want to prove so that
you've really got an example of a full
category in principle you'd have to
check all this stuff okay and it's
really really horrific so why can't we
use proof assistants to work with these
structures right well proof assistants
like cook and actor exist in there and
they're used in a lot of settings but
the trouble is of course these proof
assistants just use one-dimensional
algebra they just let you type in
strings one-dimensional string okay now
there's no reason at all that we need to
restrict ourselves to this there's no
reason we to it restrict ourselves to
formalizing compositional concepts with
computers only in a one-dimensional way
we're sort of used to this with
graphical user interfaces right and
windows okay we can arrange things in
two dimensions we can use basically the
same sort of geometrical ideas in our
proof assistants I claim so we have a
solution to this myself and my
collaborators it's called globular it's
a proof assistant for higher category
theory and it's available right now at
this web address if you have a computer
we're going to do a demo and you can
follow along if you would like if you
have Chrome and you wanted to fire that
up so it's been we've been very pleased
with with the level of success that this
is
in terms of people being interested
engaged with it it's been around for
almost a year my PhD students made me a
nice first globular first birthday cake
last week which is very nice loaded over
9000 times by over 2,000 people right
now maybe most of this is me right but
not you could say no stenosis it's me I
mean if I mean we were expecting two
orders of magnitude land we would have
been happy with like you know if 20
people had showed an interest in this
right okay so so so who's behind this
Christoph by my student Alex Kissinger
who's not here who's in Nijmegen myself
so it has many features which we find to
be attractive first firstly I'm very
important it runs in the browser there's
absolutely no barriers to use if you
come across a link to some proof in this
system you can click on the link and
then you'll be right there instantly
nothing to download nothing to compile
no dependencies to updates you don't
need to you don't need to change your
your your your file system of your
computer you don't need to reinstall
your kernel right so of course there's a
syntax but it's not a syntax that we're
familiar with from something like Coke
and Agra it's because there's a higher
dimensional syntax so we interact with
it just by clicking and dragging and
using the mouse you can one could
generate images with this thing to use
in ones paper there are many people who
write who maybe people in this room and
many people not in this room write
papers full of pictures these pictures
suppose to be formal objects that that
explain or or account for the results
that they're presenting but how are
these pictures produced we'll just with
something like like Photoshop or
something right or some vector graphics
package there is not a formal object
these are not pictures being produced by
some proof assistant usually they're
just pictures being produced by
something oh what a pixel isn't it knows
what it needs for a pixel to be one
color not another color right if there's
some mistake in this in this in this
picture right there's no plug into
Photoshop which if you make some mistake
you miss apply one of the third one of
the axioms of
all categories and your Photoshop
diagram right Photoshop isn't going to
pop up a little a little note right and
tell you you're doing the wrong thing
what if you change your proof strategy
what if you want to simplify your proof
it's extremely hard so we can get around
lots of those problems here but even
better right even better than
downloading I'm just losing up your
paper include a direct link in your PDF
so people can click they'll be taken
straight to your proof and they can
interact with it they can scan through
it they can explore it they could even
change it they can try and simplify it
ok and this supports proofs up to the
level of semi strict for categories so
four dimensional composition so that's
pretty high it's already beyond the
level at which these things become
really easy to visualize so the
computational support is something
that's helpful in that the most sorts of
dimensions okay so time for a demo so
I'm going to switch to my browser and
I'm going to go to globular science so
here it is I'm going to go full screen
so globular works with presentations of
higher categories okay so you give you
you give the building blocks for the
structures you want to build then it the
cobbler helps you glue them together so
what we start with is a single zero cell
it's called cell one we can change the
name of our structures so I tell my
mouse on will help so let's call this
let's call this cell a we can also
change the color okay there we go I
spent a long time choosing nice soothing
initial colors my favorite shade of blue
okay so what can we do not very much all
we can do well one thing we can do is
create a new zero Celsius and you want
let's call it B now we can't really
compose anything yet because these are
just zero cells they don't go there
objects they don't go from anything to
anything we can't really do anything
with them yet
so what we need to do to get some notion
of compositionality is we need to
construct someone sells some morphisms
okay now in this system an N cell is
defined by precisely two things its
source n minus-1 diagram and its target
and minus one
diagram so we want to build a one cell
so we have to give a source and a target
so we get to break the symmetry here
let's click a and choose for it to be
the source so we click source over here
on the right and then it comes down
there in the corner so we remember what
we're doing now let's click B now let's
click target accept I can press T on my
keyboard you see there's a little
underlined T so I can press the team so
now we've got this thing called cell 3
we can click on it and it'll come up
large and we can try to understand why
has it drawn this picture to represent
cell 3
well the idea is this we start over here
with a you see it's blue and if we move
our mouse cursor over the picture it
will show us what we're looking at so
here's a okay now as we go along we've
got a we've got a we've got a we've got
a cell 3 happens and now we've got B
bbbbbb
ok so cell 3 exists to do nothing more
nothing less than turn a into B and so
over time we get this sort of trace so
cell 3 happens in the middle x 0 if you
like ok so still we can't do any
composition because cell 3 goes from A
to B so we can't compose it yet so let's
make another one so let's make something
going from B to a so I click B red press
s I click a and I press T so now I've
got cell for as well so 4 has got the
opposite type so now we're ready to do
some composition so let's try this
start the compositionality ok so I'm
going to click cell 3 and this will come
up larger this is the current diagram
that we're building and I want to attach
cell 4 so I'll click cell 4 and I'll be
told there's two ways to attach it I can
attach it on the left here on the right
and it's checking the types you see and
it's seeing that both of these are
possible because here we're blue on the
left and cell for is blue on the right
so we can attach it on the left and here
we're red on the right that cell for is
blue on the left so we can indeed attach
itself for on the right as well so it's
giving us both those options so let's
choose one of those that's choose this
one
now this is a composite diagram it's not
one of the building blocks on the left
it's a non-trivial way to connect those
together but now we can use this as the
source of a to sell so let's click
source now for the identity for the
target of this to sell I have to choose
another one cell so I've tricked a here
I can't use this this is a zero cell but
I can click identity over here and this
will give me the identity one cell on a
so this is like a just existing over
time and now I cooked our --get and I
will have a source and a target for a to
sell to or construct that to sell and
here it is will it sell five so one
earth is going on here there seems to be
some richness here how does it know to
draw this picture from the information
that we gave it well first let's
understand where that source and target
and living inside this diagram so
remember the source was cell 3 and then
cell for cell 3 turned a into B and so
forth and B into a if we read along the
bottom boundary of the picture that's
exactly what we have we have a a a a a a
a cell 3 BBB BBB BBB cell for AAA so
that source that we specified is drawn
along the bottom it's the bottom
boundary what about the target that was
just the identity on a and indeed that's
what we can see on the top so how is it
drawn this picture well it's taken the
cone over the bottom boundary and
squashed it into a point it's taken the
cone over the top boundary and squashed
into a point the top and it just ripple
so you can't see anything
and instead of drawing these are
straight lines that's drawn them a sort
of arty curved lines to make it look a
bit more graphically sophisticated and
then it's just drawn a blob in the
middle to patch over the singularity
where all the cones were joined and it's
called this blob cell 5 which is what we
call this this too so that we've built
okay so now what we're going to do in
this demo is we're going to look at the
idea of an equivalence and we're going
to prove a non-trivial theorem loving an
equivalence in a two category and
luckily this is part of the data that we
need so I'm going to build the rest of
the
the rest of the structure a little bit
faster than we were going before using
the keyboard shortcuts if you sort of
know and this is where I said if you can
follow along sorry it's a bit tough
because I'm now doing at SuperSpeed so
here we've got three more two cells just
the different colors and the different
orientations and that thing we just had
but now for an equivalence we also need
some additional rules so let's just
change the names a bit so it's a bit
easier to see why this is something
called an equivalence so a zero cells
are going to be called a and B my one
cells are going to be called F and G and
let's call these alpha eater no she's a
magician she's not here Delta okay all
right so let's look at something like
gamma so why is this part of something
called an equivalence well the idea is
that we can think of a and B the the
blue and red regions as as categories
and F and G as functors that go between
these categories and these functors are
supposed to be witnessing the fact that
a and B are equivalent categories okay
so if they're equivalent to each other
then what does that mean
what's this structure gamma that we've
built or along the bottom we start at B
we pass to a and then we pass back to B
again
well if a and B are equivalent then why
did we bother doing that we could have
just stayed it'd be all along and it
would be the same okay and this process
gamma is a process that says if you if
you do this complicated thing go from
start from a bigger to a go back to B
again you may as well have just stayed
it be all along and we have all the
different variants of this rule so
that's an advanced feature of the tool
if you click invertible then it
generates a lot of structure which is
just the structure I'm putting here by
hand so I don't want to use there's
bacon things I want to do it manually
okay but now we can compose in higher
dimensions before we did the composition
along a line but now these tiles are
two-dimensional so we can compose in the
plane and we do that just by clicking so
I'm going want to perform a composite
here I've got alpha I'm going to click
down here and it will tell me everything
that can be attached beta can be
attached and
I can be attached and if I move my mouse
cursor over it will show me where they
attach so beta I can plug into the
bottom there gamma I can plug into the
middle there if you look at the types
then that makes sense so I'm going to
attach beta at that point so here we
start at a and then we pass to a and
then B then a then we pass just to a
again and if we're going to do all of
that why didn't we just stay at a the
whole time not do any of this if a and B
are equivalent categories so this is
still path of definition of equivalence
if I can do all of this then I may as
well just have the identity on the
identity on a the whole time okay and
then there are a few more variants of
this that we can build which I will
build again at some speed it's a bit
hard to see what I'm doing because all
the cells I'm creating off the bottom
down here so I've created some of these
guys okay so this yes right and I little
bit with the color reversed
right so now this is all the data that
specifies an equivalency it's literally
just a graphical transcription the
definition of an equivalence between
categories that you might find in a
textbook on high category theorem so now
we're going to prove our theorem our
theorem is the following stated into the
traditional terminology it says that any
equivalence between categories gives
rise to an adjoint equivalence so an
adjoint equivalence is an equivalence
that additionally satisfies the
following equation so so let's build it
up so we're going to start with alpha
here I want to attach a wire on the
right so I'm going to click near the
right hand boundary and it will attach
an F it news with action F and not a G
because a G wouldn't make any sense to
attach though if G needed to needed a
red region on the left but an F needs
blue on the left so that was fine I'm
going to click here and I'm going to
attach a Delta so to have an to have an
adjoint equivalence means that if we
have this composite then we can
transform this into the identity okay
that's what it means to have an adjoint
equivalence further and above the
equations we've the structures we've
currently got now it is not true that
every equivalence is an adroit
equivalence so it is not possible in
this rewrite system to transform this
diagram into the identity diagram okay
that's not what the theorem says the
theorem doesn't say that every color is
an adjoint equivalence says that every
equivalence gives rise in a canonical
way in a number of commands always to so
let's say Don canonically to an adjoint
equivalence okay so how does it do that
well we need to redefine one of these
structures Alpha Beta Gamma Delta
so let's redefine Delta so we're going
to redefine it so we have to produce
something else that's got the same
overall type as Delta so we need the
same lower boundary in the same upper
boundary but we can make the diagram
itself be more complicated so let's do
some attachments I'm going to attach
beta up here and I'm going to attach
gamma
here so we've got something that looks
like the bottom end of a hockey stick
but if you check the types it's still
got the same overall type as this
structure that we started with red
identity along the top and red blue red
sorry red I dented on the bottom and red
blue red across the top so now we want
to store this we want to use this as a
definition of a new structure and for
that strangely we're going to click the
theorem button why on earth does theorem
mean definition so it's a strange idea
but from the perspective of higher
category Theory there's no difference at
all between a theorem and the definition
why on earth should this be well let's
try and talk about a theorem in a way
that makes it sound a lot more systems a
lot more similar to a definition when we
give a theorem we we give it a give us a
theorem statement okay and in this sort
of setting that's always of the form
such-and-such a cell exists with a
certain type and then we give a proof
well that's just showing how we can
actually instantiate we can actually
come up with a witness of something of
that type from the basic structure but
that's just the same as a definition is
just the same as we're going to define a
new structure to be a given composite in
our existing structures and then the
overall type of that structure that
we're defining that is as our theorem
statement if you will so when I click
theory which is two new things and new
tile a new two dimensional tile with the
same type as Delta so we could call that
new Delta
and then down here they constructed a
3-cell it tells us the definition of a
new Delta it tells us how to transform
Delta into sorry it transfers from new
Delta into a composite and our original
structures so now we can try and prove
that the this this family where we throw
away Delta but we instead keep new Delta
is an adjoint equivalence so let's have
a look at that adjoint equation so I'm
going to build the same equation that I
did before by clicking or within the
periphery of the diagram and choosing
from the list of disambiguate when there
are multiple things that could be
attached so now here's the snake and
we're going to show that this can be
rewritten into the identity so what's
the first step we're going to do well
the what we want to so the first thing
we're going to do is is is its tell
gobbler that we want to remember
everything that we're doing cuz this is
the proof we're going to construct now
we want to remember all the steps of the
proof so we don't just want to transform
this 2d thing into the final 2d thing we
want to remember the whole sequence of
2d steps we want to construct a 3d proof
object so for that we click the identity
button over here on the right a bit more
about that later so now what's the first
non trivial proof step while we're going
to substitute in the definition of nu
Delta so for that we click there are a
few things that can be done in this
region we're going to apply the
definition of nu Delta so now we've got
this ok it looks pretty bad ok because
we said that so this is now all in terms
of our original Alpha Beta Gamma Delta
now it looks pretty much looks worse
than before because we said that
whenever we had a single little snake
composite we couldn't rewrite it into
the identity and now we've got two of
them one inside the other so how can we
rewrite this into the identity well like
lots of complicated some non-trivial
proofs we have to make this more
complicated before it gets simpler
before we turn it just into a single
straight line so the first thing we're
going to introduce is a little red
bubble over here in this blue sea so I
could do that by clicking I could also
do it by choosing the move that I want
so I want this move this move introduces
a red bubble in a blue sea so I'm going
to click here and then globular will
tell me all the places where I
do this if I move my mouse over then
there's highlights come up large I want
to do it about here okay so now I want
to cut through these two walls here so
where's the rule for that it's down here
click here and it shows me everywhere
the supplies I want to do it here okay
now we can start to apply some isotopy
to this diagram this is the whole point
of high dimensional algebra isotope ease
of the plain act on algebraic structures
and in globular the idea is that this is
visceral you reach out you grab a node
and you pull it up or down so this blue
node here I want to drag it down so I
click and drag this blue node here I
want to drag it up I click and drag it I
do it again now this is a bit more
interesting here we've got Delta facing
off against Gamma Delta could be pulled
down to the right or to the left both of
those would be topologically permissible
and you do that by dragging at a certain
angle so if I drag down Delta down and a
little bit to the right you see it'll go
down here I can check it back up again I
can drag it down and a little to the
left okay so let's keep let's keep sort
of playing around what so why are we
playing around well maybe as is often
the case in high category theory you
don't know how to prove the thing you're
trying to prove well you don't even know
if it's true right you're doing
spiritual matters this is of course
always the case in science so that's the
first role that this tool can play
helping you to explore and play around
with a set of algebraic structures to
see what's possible ok so we don't know
what we're doing we're we're we're
playing around well then we notice we
can do something a bit interesting here
because gamma and Delta we can apply a
rule to sort of cancel out this gamma
and Delta so I click here and let's see
there's lots of things that apply I
could find the one that here this just
involves that gamma and Delta so I click
this cell 15
then it annihilates now let's do a
little bit more rearrangement now we see
here this might be a good place to apply
an operation here cell 15
okay and now we're doing pretty well now
we'll we're left with is two red bubbles
and we know that we can kill red bubbles
and we'll just get the identity so let's
find our rule
lets us kill a red bubble here it is if
I click this nothing comes up there's no
matches it's not letting me apply the
rule why is it not letting me apply the
rule because the matching algorithm that
it's using is absolutely exact we have
to literally see this exact little tile
is a sub diagram of our main image and
we're not seeing that right these red
bubbles are too tall because these this
critical point here of this other bubble
is is interleaved with these two points
so we've got to fix that problem first
there's many ways we could we could fix
that problem for example we could sort
of pull this up here and now we can kill
both of these red bubbles so if I click
here it'll tell me this rule matches in
two places so we choose one and which is
the other one we're done we've rewritten
from the snake to the identity so we've
proved our theorem now that was great so
so the first thing we would ask is what
on earth did we do okay maybe we're
doing something far more complicated
than this what on earth did we do well
we can see what we did because you might
have noticed this slice command has been
incrementing as we've been going so if
we if we change the slice command we can
see everything that we did and we could
look through that and we say oh yeah
that bit where I just put these guys up
and down that was pointless that didn't
help me achieve my goal so you could
look at that and you could learn from it
and you could try and do better next
time construct a more efficient proof
but something else that you can do as
visualize this proof in a completely
different way so as I've already alluded
to here we've got two DS slices each
stage of our proof is a 2d slice we
could imagine printing out these slices
and literally stacking them as pieces of
paper one on top of another what we have
in front of us would be a 3d object a
stack of 30 sheets of paper okay one way
to visualize that it's like a like a cat
scan right to slice through it another
way to visualize that is to look at it
from the side and imagine what would be
the effective 2d picture that you would
see from the side and what you'll see is
as each of these vertices move up and
down in the slices from the side these
points trace out world lines that move
around and and and interleave each other
so what we want to do is project out the
third dimension we do that with the
project control so we go up here the
moment we're projecting out zero
dimensions instead we want to project
out one dimension and we get this image
it's a single image that represents our
entire proof and it looks a bit like a
knot well why is that
well knots are bits of string embedded
in 3-space here we've got rewrites in
Beda's effectively in 3-space and it
turns out that you know topology and
how's your product closely related as
you might have heard right this is just
an instance of it now this is a bit more
complicated than the diagrams we've seen
before so we can use the zoom feature we
can use the scroll wheel on our mouse we
can move around these each of these
lines and now Alpha Beta Gamma Delta the
lines and other things that used to be
vertices because now we're seeing the
world lines that these algebraic spaces
structures are tracing out over the
course of the proof and now in efficient
in efficiencies in our proof become
absolutely clear here we braided this
green strand over the red strand and
then back again okay topologically this
isn't helping us achieve our goal which
is sort of right at the top so we can
cancel this out how would you cancel
how would you eradicate this how would
you get rid of this if you were really
looking at bits of string in front of
you well you might put your finger in
here and slide it down and tease the
strings apart so that's exactly the user
interface mechanic that we have here we
click say at this crossing and we pull
it down and it will cause them to cancel
out so what else can we do here so so so
so we can manipulate this as a 3d entity
although albeit one that we're seeing in
the two-dimensional projection so we can
also pull things up and down just as we
could before but now in 3d there are new
types of isotopy that are allowed so
here we apply a move and then we cross
both these strands over the blue strand
right we may as well have just have just
have just only bothered applying this
move on the other side it would be much
simpler now to do that we grab this pink
vertex and we pull it up and it will
move it across okay so in this way we
can affect all sorts of we can
affect all sorts of simplifications of
our proof okay and I'm not saying
alright we can pull this down list down
we can cancel this out we can pull this
up and cancel this out you can do all
sorts of stuff okay now let's say we get
it into a state that we're happy with
what about the original 2d slices right
where have they gone because that's the
actual full detailed content of the
proof well it's all still there we were
manipulating our entire proof was a 3d
object we can just revisit now in terms
of the original 2d slices so we set
projected to zero and now we can see a
far more efficient proof well that
wasn't very efficient was it there we
obviously didn't finish the job but this
proof is only 18 slices long it was 30
before okay so I hope you see from this
demonstration the point of globular you
can build up an algebraic system you can
work with the components you can play
around with trying to construct proofs
you can simplify your proofs and now if
we wanted to we could publish this in
and then the globular server would
assign this a permanent sort of archival
number a bit like the archive and then
you could use that as a permanent URL to
link from your from your from your
research paper okay so let's just talk
to in a few minutes to finish about the
theory what's going on here that allows
this to happen I think it fits in nicely
with this description description of
semantics that we've had this morning so
two words signatures and diagrams a
signature as a list of allowed moves
that we're going to have in our
categories the generators of our high
categorical structure it's all the stuff
we have down the left-hand side of the
tool a diagram represents a generic
composite of moves its way to fits
together lots of moves into a single
composed structure so this is an example
of a diagram okay if the sort we've seen
before now a crucial point and it was
this was one of the greatest insights I
think that we had as a team in producing
this tool is that we only work with
diagrams which in generic position that
means we never have two vertices at
exactly the same height now if you're
doing category theory on paper or you're
looking at research
you will often see multiple diagrams at
the same heart but we don't allow that
and it allows us to use an extremely
simple data structure to encode this
diagram let's see what that data
structure is how do we encode this
two-dimensional diagram well the first
thing we do is we encode its source ok
so we do this and then we do this and
then we do this we just give a list of
the stuff that we do ok so it's just
this list and we just encode that as a
list in the obvious way because these
things have all got names so that's easy
now how do we encode the 2 dimensional
diagram well what we do is we give a
list of instructions we say at each
height which 2d tile are we going to
attach and at what coordinate so if you
like how many wires are to the left of
my tile when I attach it to the source
well there are no wires to the left here
so we say we're going to do this tile
with nowise to the left then we attach
this tile with one wire to the left then
we attach this tile with no wires to the
left then we attach this tile with one
wire to the left so this diagram is
encoded recursively by first encoding
its source and then encoding the list of
the list of two dimension tiles that he
used ordered by the height at which they
appear in the diagram in this way now if
two tiles appeared at the same height
you couldn't order them so this list
structure would have to become a lot
more complicated and that has a huge
number of ramifications down the line
because this basic data structure is
what all of our operations are acting on
rewriting for example whenever we
rewrite these structures it's so helpful
that they're so simple so in what ways
do we rewrite them well in order to have
to be doing category theory we need this
sense of isotope in which we've seen so
what we do is we identify different
fundamental types of isotopy we've got
alpha b2 here in the plane we can
exchange them if we've got alpha here
above another another wire that's in the
background we can slide alpha down and
there's a few more things that we can do
all of these equations these sort of
families of equations family was 1 2 3 4
& 5 these are all well known these are
well understood in the category through
literature's being important these are
the ones that we use and then we could
use this to give new simple definitions
of higher category theory we can say
that if we say that an N signature is
just a signature list of rules which is
at most of some dimension n then we say
a semi strict two category is a three
signature that supports moves of type
one the three category is the signature
of supporting moves of types one and two
and A four category is a signature
supporting moves of types one two three
four and five so in this way we get a
concrete definition say of semi strict
for category which is vastly simpler
than existing definitions which as I
said before something like 74 requires
suspect to define a semi strict for
category traditional you have to give
something like 70 functions and check
this satisfy one hundred and forty
axioms we've reduced that by an order of
magnitude how have we done that really
well because we're not trying to give a
syntactic definition of a four or seven
street for category we're doing it in a
semantical way we're saying here's a
very very very simple data structure
which is which which which which allows
the axioms of which allows on which the
axioms of a semi strict for category or
in general a high category to act in a
in a way that doesn't lose any
information so forget about the axioms
of higher category theory as
conventionally proposed just work with
these data structures this very simple
list based data structure and then you
can play with your your four categories
or your n categories and you can
construct formal proofs to your heart's
content so thanks for listening
hey Jeff you can stop you said I can to
dispatch he'll have to move things
around right it's a deliberate mistake
Pablo 2.0 right can I have a button that
says yeah maybe yeah maybe yeah because
that's not actually so so so what Pavel
is also what problem is saying there's
at the certain point I want to apply a
move and I couldn't apply the move but
only because I need to do a little bit
of isotopy first now because of so so
why couldn't globally have coped with
that for me why couldn't it have been a
little bit intelligent so that's
absolutely what we the sort of thing we
want to do so I've called this a proof
assistant but really it's just like a
clever piece of paper it doesn't do
anything for you other than storing the
structures that you construct but once
you've got that as a foundation it's
fully formal and you can have tactics
and you can have these automated
techniques so in particular because of
how isotopy is formalized in globular
that the space of isis or pieces of a
particular diagram is always finite so
you could certainly write some procedure
that would just let it that would scan
through all those possible ices of these
and you know you might have a huge
number of matches which was very useful
but may sometimes you just have a small
number of matches then that would really
help you find your proof right so that
that's right that there are there's
another data structure you can use which
precisely identifies two diagrams just
to win their isotopic and that's
actually an extremely simple procedure
but the trouble with that it doesn't
tell you doesn't help you with the
problem of matching because matching is
ill-defined in that in that case where
if you quotient by Isis hopping because
as we've seen right it matters exactly
how you layer your diagram out whether
or not there will be a match so that's
the problem that's introduced
is it fair to say you've achieved this
simplification in the definitions of the
higher categories
taking all the complexity that was there
stuffing it into the search problem
finding proofs in the first place no I
don't think that complex that I don't
think that was the complexity that was
in these axioms we've thrown away huge
numbers so what on earth are these 140
axioms well in a four category you've
got four ways you can compose in four
dimensions of all those composites all
those compositions are associative all
those compositions are unitl we throw
all of those axioms away because we
represent everything as a list a list
does have associative composition it's a
theorem about lists not an axiom write
lists do have strictly unitl composition
because if you've got a list with the
empty list you get back the list you
started with that's not an axiom that's
a theorem that you could prove if you
want to and indeed in our paper that's
where the theoretical work is here we
don't have any proofs saying that this
definition of censorship for critic that
we get agrees with any previous
definition but we have lots of thoughts
of really non-trivial theorems at least
that the proofs that were hard to find
we found the proofs hard to find in the
proof so like long showing that huge
numbers of properties that in in in
traditional approaches to care to be
through our axioms come out now as
theorems and we got a lot of work
proving those theorems to give
confidence in our approach right so we
haven't got a proof of that do you have
a guess for what somebody strict v yeah
so so so so be strict for counter view
is really kind of nice because there was
only one previous definition of some
strict for count degree and it was a bit
sort of rubbish right I mean it's very
impressive for what it was but really if
we're going to list 140 axioms it's
quite hard to do it in tidy way without
making any mistakes and it was it was
quite old work and there are some some
of those homotopy moves I described
weren't sort of known about then so
there's some stuff there that's missing
but yes we have a systematic way of
understanding well
only through talking to John that I
discovered this he's planted this
question so I could say yes you don't
like it okay so there are beautiful
high-level ways of understanding all the
different ways you can compose stuff so
here this is just saying we've got so
why does this move exist well really it
is X exists we might want to have alpha
and beta at exactly the same height
we're not allowed to have it exactly the
same height so the next best thing is to
go have moves that go between the two
ways of breaking or breaking the
symmetry here why does this move arise
because we might want to have alpha
exactly in front this wire that runs
behind it but that's not allowed in the
system because it's generic so the next
pressed thing we can have is a move that
lets us go from this way of breaking the
symmetry to this way of breaking the
symmetry so in other words all of these
axioms arise from disallowed
compositions and these disallowed
compositions of this well-known
combinatorially how to list them all
using these things called button in
trees so we can just list all button
entries of a certain class and then they
give us all these moves and then in
principle we could implement them but I
mean it gets a bit it gets a bit
horrific and and you have the
fundamental problem that if you want to
do n categories and there's no finite
amount of programming that will get you
to infinity categories right because you
have to handle each case by hand each
dimension there's more stuff so I mean
we what we're going to do something
better for 2.0 yeah so this is all
purely geometrical there's no support
for anything like that but it would be
great to have a way to take some you
know some some composite structure like
this and say well wait a minute this
these wires really represent vector
spaces these vertices really represent
linear maps or any other sort of
structure of course because you can use
political categories you know because
one can imagine a functor from this
syntax into any sort of interesting
target category and then you could ask
globular to do the composition for you
to compose all these linear it's linear
detail these function data whatever it
is and exactly the way that the diagram
encodes so that's something we'd like to
do
when you introduce the newest self can
both the source and the target be a
laboratory compass it's yes yeah so
thanks for your questions so we so so
what are the applications of this area
well a huge application is not theory
there's a guy called Scott Carter which
some of you might know because he just
leased a lot thirty has lots of
beautiful he has lots of beautiful work
sort of in the area of descriptive
topology I'm not sure if that's not a
bit of a rude phrase or not I should ask
him
basically the lot of conjectures in in
not theory say that this knot is
isotopic to this other knot and the way
you there's no real clever way to do it
you should got to find the okay that's
very clever you should but you've just
got to find the isotopy and visualize it
so a great example is a great example is
let's see so let's see so a great
example if we go to the globular and
that page we've got tons of examples so
they're about 40 public proofs that we
published here's a list of some of them
so one here the Perko knots the isotopic
so what does it say here the purko knots
are a pair of ten crossing not stated by
little to be distinct but proven by
purko a grad student at MIT i think or
somewhere on the East Coast
actually to be isotopic okay now now
apocryphal I mean I mean you know the
legend goes he was on his kitchen table
with this you know some rope that he'd
arranged in the in the form of one of
these knots and he was manipulating it
yeah and he was manipulating it you know
he started laying it out in the manner
of pocos first knot and then you know
twelve hours later he realized it was
now Coco's second on they weren't cool
because presses are maybe he called him
that you know what else build event at
the time but then what is the first
thing that he would think what on earth
what what did i do what did i do yeah he
folds up his supervisor says I've done
it well what did you do I have no clue
if you look at this out so we so we
formalized this could be formalized this
and it's here and of course we're
running out of time but it's 250 steps
so this is the first this is pokers
first not right and we
we go through and we apply the right
amounts to rip moves right oh my sister
one we have to put in by hand Rida
Meister two and three we don't have to
put in by hand because they're just
axioms of three categories that's really
very simple
slice 250 this is Perkis second not now
in his in his research paper that he
published in 1974 describing this
isotopic he gives five pictures right
that are supposed to be the descriptions
of this isotope we write the idea I
guess but you know each picture was
really like 50 moves in this absolutely
fine-grained sense because what else can
you do I mean and it's impressive enough
that he managed to capture the whole
thing in his head in a way that allowed
him to present it at all with a tool
like this I think it would have helped
him I don't know apparently he quite
likes when people email him about his
Isis office I'll do that right so often
it might be undecidable weather weather
in general so in general it's
undecidable weather two knots are
isotopic that doesn't mean that there
aren't some concrete conjectures that
you may or may not be able to solve but
it's hard stuff in general didn't he
came up with
[Applause]